il coûte casimir du que vient de rendre
ce service
j'en ai pas pour longtemps jeu c'est
toujours pareil il faut tout le temps
que je garde août et ballon ou le chlore
scozzoli vraiment si on aurait pu s'y
rendre service dans l'île aux enfants la
vie va devenir impossible
je sais mais qu'est ce que tu veux mon
moi je vais m'ennuyer au bout d'une
heure qu'a faire quelque chose je sais
pas moi du tien répète les pas de danse
que julie théâtre i dernière notre à ben
oui ça c'est une très bonne idée
oui oui mais on peut faire deux choses à
la fois c'est vrai pour me coûte 20 ans
j'ai besoin d'être sens là je te
remercie casimir givet là c'est ce qu'on
peut appeler changer d'avis alors oui 1
2 3 4 à papa me tape à me pas t'attendre
pas d'amis pas moi vous avez une chance
inouïe c'est je disais que vous aviez
une chance inouïe
j'ai de la chance moi est-ce que vous
avez rencontré ces formules en tchador
avoir de la chance et pourquoi est ce
que j'ai de la chance bien parce que
vous avez rencontré site une chance ah
bah oui parce que vous apporte
exactement le produit qui manquait à
votre bonne en mai mais je suis
parfaitement heureux et bien dorénavant
vous serez 13 heures grâce à ma patte
universel et c'est quoi cette pâte aux
vermicelles universel pâte universel ça
veut dire une pâte qui peut servir à
tous avec cette pâte vous voulez vous
brosser les dents ou bien encore faire
une tarte ou bien même vous en servir
comme comme pâte à modeler points moi je
vous remercie vous en ai vraiment fort
boyard vj n'est pas attendez attendez
attendez tout acheteur d'un tube de pâte
universelle a le droit de faire le grand
concours super extra géant de la pâte
universel et c'est grave
le cube au delà du concours le premier
prix est un voyage autour du monde
ah mais ça c'est formidable un voyage
autour du monde
oui vous voulez goûter un jeu peut
essayer we dare je vais vous j'ai dit
bien haut sinon les pourtant délicieuse
avec son petit goût de noisette
il allait trop sucré il ça manque de
moutarde ne se risque d'un peu de
confiture de groseilles quelques cas
d'exposants prise au vent c'est non non
je vous remercie
non elle est trop sucrés promis non je
n'aime pas votre pas pour vernis
cellules offrent encore une fois ce
n'est pas une patte au vernissage à une
patte unique verset je voulais non bien
sûr monsieur titre de publicité
exceptionnels la société pas universelle
a le plaisir de vous offrir même une
même sans achat un bon de participation
le voilà au grand concours autour du
monde c'est vraiment gentil c'est chacun
keirrison est un concours très facile
tony martin
voici un crayon vous répondez aux
questions que vous me rendez le le
budget d'accord bon on sait en effet
très facile alors première question
facile aussi
voilà j'ai six niveaux trop con car nous
renvoyons se questionne des
remerciements mais le crayon est à moi
pardon
même si nous allions bien
un très bien bien bravo mais mais vous
avez tout bon mes mails mais vous avez
gagné le premier prix le voyage autour
du monde
c'est vraiment très intelligente et
signe ici c'est pour établir votre
billet à wil accord bien sûr est
quasiment acquise et mais qu'est-ce que
ça et que fais tu je signe mon billet
pour partir en voyage autour du monde
j'ai gagné un le concours dans la pape
aux vermicelles universel regarde j'ai
toutes les réponses border les bulletins
secrets mais ça me fait rien pour moi et
mon meilleur ami je n'ai pas fait pour
la monf abandon je vous attends un peu
plus loin de signer d'autres biais
voulais me rejoint le bateau pendant
quelques
d'accord j'arrive tout de suite à
saint-hyacinthe y tient
casimir ouais tu permets que j'appelle
les enfants henry comme ça ils pourront
me féliciter oui c'est sa part dit
assieds si les autres venaient tout le
monde tout le monde avec moi en asie me
revient de faire un concours et je
voudrais que vous me disiez si ses
réponses sont exactes vous êtes d'accord
oui oui et vous aussi chez vous parfait
vous allez voir toutes mes réponses sont
bonnes
première réponse de casimir l'abeille
est un mammifère
qu'en pensez vous non non qu'est ce que
c'est une abeille
c'est un insecte très bien rares
ensuite la méditerranée est une montagne
vous êtes sourd c'est une mère continue
en continuant à casimir les oranje ont
des noyaux dans les oranges il ya des
pépins évidemment ensuite les régions
miaule ce sont les chat qui miaule et
les vaches à lait les vaches elles me va
très bien
ensuite dernière réponse de casimir la
france est en afrique la france et en
europe
je vous remercie les enfants par famille
ça casimir
mais françois alors alors toutes mes
réponses sont mauvaises
et oui tout et c'est pas ça qui est
normal justement les cookies il faut
vite que je signe mon billet que je le
lui donne parce que sinon il va
s'apercevoir que quand je fais des
fautes mais casimir culture a vu ce que
tu allais sénile
non pourquoi ça me paraît un petit peu
louche l'autre mais c'est est un billet
ouais bon écoute dépêche-toi parce que
ceci non c'est idiot va s'apercevoir que
je me suis trompé
là c'est bien ce que je pensais casimir
ton billet tête un contrat quoi est ce
représentant de commerce n'est autre que
co qui a et b en ligne après sérieux
celui qui veut emmener dans une cage à
travers le monde pour se montrer à tout
le monde qu'on a nourri des gros monde
autrement au ruc charmant monsieur
travelling oui mais je travaille je vais
vous faire avaler tout vent tout ne peut
pas tout faire mais là ça sinon on n'est
pas fou vous avez un nom
[Musique]